you don't have to be around Jim Cameron
very long to understand that you're
working with somebody who is very
special
is uh uh incredibly creative incredibly
smart and driven driven like nobody I've
ever worked with before and nobody puts
it in as many hours nobody
cares as much uh he sets the bar High
Michael you know I think he you know
that
uh I did three movies with him
um aliens the abyss Terminator two no
Terminator Terminator one yeah yeah and
aliens and um the abyss right and add a
little part in T2 that got cut and put
back we'll get to that because you
didn't you get paid for that
let's get back stay on camera stay on
camera so uh you know Jim uh he sets the
bar High yeah so if you want to come
play with Jim Cameron you better be
prepared to uh
do your best and I think that's all he
ever asks from anybody is their bat
their best I don't I've never heard Jim
lose it it's a real one story well okay
but it is one story is it firsthand oh
yeah and he's he was right though well
he's always right there was a there was
a moment have I told that story Tom
Arnold told me this story about True
Lies he says he's in the car
and Schwarzenegger's really late
and they get into the car and Cameron
comes up to him
and just says you're [__] my day man
you're [__] my day you come up here
late God damn it I don't want to see you
[__] he goes off on him for about
five seconds ten seconds walks away all
right goes Buddy [__] why don't you
punch him in the face for that he goes
because he was right yeah you know I
I don't know where you heard that I
don't know if you heard that story I
read it because I read that story myself
I read that and that I'm sure happened
and I'm sure that that that that Jim
could could have lost it my experience
with him is that um
uh he's intense he wants things right
and he wants things done his way there
was one time when I was working with him
and uh well during the Terminator and
we're doing something and we do a take
or whatever and he said Michael that's
exactly what I don't want
and
um you know the hair on my back of my
neck went up a little bit and by this
time I'd spent much with him and I said
well okay Jim
uh here's the deal everybody on this set
knows
that you can do their job
better than they can do it
but you can't play Kyle Reese so give me
a [__] line reading and let's move on
and he did and I did and that's all
there is just remember the line
come with me if you wanna no
no I don't remember the particular one
you know what's funny you say that is I
love it when I'm trying to get something
versus no no put the emphasis no just
give me the line reading I don't care no
ego here what is it I don't want any of
you to come here great just like that
and that's it I don't want to go through
of what I think you want or trying to
just tell me what you want sometimes
that's easier well I in that case it was
one in which
um uh Jim is is blunt uh which I I would
call him blunt yeah uh he doesn't coddle
actors does he say hey Michael great job
on that tape oh yeah oh he will oh oh
yeah oh yeah because I think that's okay
and most times uh as an actor you can
for me you know it or you look over to
Jim you're good I'm good he looks at you
with a smile yeah yeah yeah no he's a he
I think he's I think he's I you know I
haven't seen Jim for probably a year
before covid
um but he's been um
and even though I haven't seen him in
four years Michael if if if right now
I picked up your phone and I'm not going
to do it but picked up your phone uh and
said I need to speak to Jim Cameron it's
an emergency I need to speak to you he I
he would get I would hear from him in 10
or 15 minutes
and he's that kind of guy you know he's
that kind of friend